[Applaudissements]
quarante mille 40 milles c'est le nombre
d'informations personnelles qui seront
volé et revendu de manière frauduleuse
sur le dark web avant la fin de mon taux
que ferez vous partie des victimes
êtes vous une proie facile pour les
pirates
la question n'est pas de savoir si vous
allez être piratés mais quand vous allez
être piratés tous les jours des gens des
citoyens des étudiants se font pirater
se font à quai comme on dit en patois de
chez nous il ya plus d'1 million de
cyberattaques quotidiennes qui vise les
étudiants les particuliers les
entreprises et même les organismes
d'état les plus sensibles alors il ya
une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle la
mauvaise nouvelle d'abord chaque
appareil téléphone pc ordinateur possède
des vulnérabilités tous les systèmes
possèdent des vulnérabilités
quand une vulnérabilité existent tôt ou
tard elle est exploitée
ça on le sait dans le monde de la
cybersécurité alors là vous allez me
dire bah on est vraiment mal
oui on est mal sauf que il y à la bonne
nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'avec quelques
règles simples vous pouvez éviter la
majorité des cyberattaques
ces règles certains les appellent des
règles de bonnes pratiques d'autres les
appels des règles de bon sens moi je
préfère les appeler des règles d'hygiène
informatique
quand on était petit nos parents nous
ont appris à nous laver les mains nous
brosser les dents
mais en informatique c'est pareil si
vous respecter quelques règles d'hygiène
vous pouvez résister au virus être
résistant aux cyberattaques
ces règles sont lequel la première les
emails 91% des cyberattaques commence
par un email si on veut reprendre une
analogie par exemple chez vous dans
votre maison
c'est comme si vous quand vous partiez
de chez vous vous laisser ouvert votre
porte pour que le facteur puisse rentrer
vous déposez vos lettres et vos colis
vous ne faites pas vous fermez la porte
de chez vous en partant et le facteur
posez-les est dans la boîte et bien les
emails
c'est la même chose en informatique
c'est la même chose il ya trois astuces
la première l'expéditeur ne pas se fier
à l'expéditeur qui est écrit en haut de
l'e-mail il peut être très facilement
usure pablo but ni modifiables deuxième
astuces à faire attention c'est le lien
les liens qui sont dans les emails ne
cliquer sur le lien que si on est
absolument sûr que l'on à être redirigés
sur le bon site est le lien qui est
écrit que l'on voit écrit dans l'e-mail
n'est pas forcément le réel lien sur
lequel vous allez être redirigé pour
connaître le réel bien sûr lequel vous
allez être redirigé il faut approcher sa
souris dessus sur le lien sans et
cliquer et là vous voyez apparaître le
réel site sur lequel vous à être
envoyées troisième astuces les pièces
jointes ne jamais exécuté ouvrir une
pièce jointe
si on n'est pas sûr qu'elle n'est pas
infecté pour ça on peut la scanner vous
avez tous des antivirus sur vos
ordinateurs scannella avec l'antivirus
avant de l'ouvrir
j'ai encore reçu un e-mail hier d'un
prince saoudien qu'il voulait me léguer
sa fortune son héritage bien sûr à moins
et malheureusement il avait besoin de
mes codes bancaires ce que je me suis
empressé de faire lui donner non il faut
faire très attention quand on renvoie
des informations aussi aux gens en email
quand on envoie les informations faut
s'assurer que le destinataire est bien
le bon et des informations personnelles
c'est aussi ça de la valeur et les
pirates essaye de ramasser ces
informations pour les revendre donc ne
renvoyez pas d'informations personnelles
de code de logging etc
si vous n'êtes pas sûrs à qui vous les
envoyez une manière générale ne les
envoyer par email est ce qu'un e-mail
n'est pas sûr deuxième règle d'hygiène
les mots de passe
breaking news un mot de passe de six
caractères se casse en 12 secondes et
statistiquement 50% des mots de passe se
casse en 50 minutes
si on veut reprendre l'analogie de notre
maison fut un temps les maisons
n'avaient pas de serrure
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de voleurs et
puis quand les voleurs sont apparus on a
mis des verrous sur nos portes et
aujourd'hui quand on part de chez nous
on ferme la porte à clé et bien le
verrou de votre ordinateur c'est votre
mot de passe
il faut qu'ils soient sécurisés il faut
qu'il soit sûr faut qu'il fonctionne
vous connaissez les règles 12 caractères
minimum
mais l'imam à shief minimum une
majuscule
mais il y eut même une minuscule mais
l'imam un caractère spécial et en plus
de tout ça il faut pas deux fois le même
mot de passe pour deux services
différents
bien sûr sinon ce serait trop facile
alors là vous allez me dire c'est
impossible
oui on n'est pas des machines on peut
pas retenir 50 100 200 mots de passe
comme ça mais vous n'avez pas besoin de
les retenir
c'est ça la bonne nouvelle parce
qu'aujourd'hui il existe des coffres
forts de mot de passe
un coffre fort de mots de passe est un
logiciel soit que vous installez sur
votre ordinateur soit en ligne qui
stocke vos mots de passe de manière
chiffrée sécurisé et vous n'avez plus de
mots de passe à retenir et vous n'avez
plus de mots de passe a tapé puisque la
plupart des coffres forts de mots de
passes vont aller saisir vos
identifiants votre login et votre mot de
passe quand vous êtes sur internet à
votre place donc c'est plus efficace
plus sécurisé et plus rapide par contre
pour accéder au coffre fort de mot de
passe
il va falloir un mot de passe sécurisé
et oui vous n'avez plus qu'à un mot de
passe à retenir mais c'est celui là
quand même
il faut qu'ils soient sécurisés alors
l'a inventé vous un moyen mnémotechnique
par exemple la méthode phonétique
c'est un super texte
ou une citation ou une phrase ou une des
paroles de chansons que vous aimez au
soleil sous la pluie à midi à minuit ou
alors une phrase que vous aimez bien
l'informatique c'est fantastique
inventer vous vous technique votre
astuce mnémotechnique pour retenir votre
mot de passe
et même si certains de ces mots de passe
ne respectent pas les règles que l'on a
vu juste avant ils sont quand même
sécurisé parce que la longueur rajoute
de la résistance au mot de passe
troisième règle d'hygiène les
sauvegardes 25 % des propriétaires de pc
des utilisateurs de pc perdent des
données dans l'année donc là
statistiquement c'est pas vous êtes
300-400 mallet il va ya peut-être 100
personnes qui vont perdre des données
cette année si on reprend notre analogie
de notre maison c'est comme si vous
n'aviez pas l'assurance habitation
s'il ya un problème une inondation le
feu ou perdez tout il faut avoir un
filet de sécurité elles filet de
sécurité en informatique c'est la
sauvegarde
alors une bonne sauvegarde c'est quoi
une vraie sauvegarde
c'est une sauvegarde qui respecte la
règle du 3 2 1 trois copies différente
du des fichiers sur deux types de
supports différents
avec au moins une sauvegarde
externalisée et une sauvegarde hors
ligne là c'est pareil vous allez me dire
c'est une usine à gaz que tu vas nous
faire installer non ça peut être très
simple trois copies différentes par
exemple vous avez vos fichiers sur votre
ordinateur
vous avez un disque dur externe chez
vous ou une clé usb sur lequel vous
faites les sauvegardes régulièrement que
vous gardez là chez vous et puis une
externalisée orleans ça veut dire que fo
a qu'à l'extérieur de chez vous vous
ayez par exemple un deuxième disque dur
par exemple chez vos parents même s'ils
voulaient fait que très rarement
vous allez les voir qu'une fois par an à
noël pendant que les escargots cuisent
dans le four vous faites votre
sauvegarde annuel externalisés et hors
ligne
voilà ça c'est un système de sauvegarde
qui fonctionne qui est résistant et qui
respecte la règle du 3 2 1
il faut identifier ce que vous avez
besoin de sauvegarder
vous avez toujours des documents que
vous les gardez des photos des vidéos
des cours votre compte à et c'est au
projet vous avez vous avez toujours des
fichiers à sauvegarder
il faut les identifier et les copier
quatrième et dernière règles d'hygiène
les mises à jour 99% des cyber attaques
passent par un système où un logiciel
qui n'est pas à jour
ça veut dire qu'en faisant les mises à
jour on se protège contre ces cyber
attaques que ce soit sur un ordinateur
un téléphone une tablette
il faut faire les mises à jour si on
reprend notre analogie de la maison
c'est comme si vous aviez vos fenêtres
qui ferment plus par exemple
et du coup ça se voit de la rue vous
êtes obligés de les réparer faux les
faux les réparer au plus vite parce que
votre maison sinon reste ouverte et main
l'informatique sur votre ordinateur
c'est pareil sur votre téléphone c'est
pareil sur tablette
que vous ayez un iphone un téléphone
android
une tablette android ipad etc un
ordinateur mac windows
il faut faire les mises à jour c'est
très important
alors
maintenant vous êtes calais en avant en
hygiène informatique
alors ce soir en vous brossant les dents
pensez aussi à ces quatre règles
d'hygiène qui vous permettront de
résister à la majorité des cyber
attaques que ce soit au bureau ou à la
maison
serez vous votre meilleur allié pour
combattre la cybercriminalité
merci merci